President Trump says he is considering
putting some parts of the hardest hit
States under a 14 day quarantine amid
fears that new coronavirus hotspots are
emerging this all comes as the World
Health Organization is under the
microscope for not acting faster when
the first cases were reported in China
dr. Dan field is chief medical officer
at m.d. staffers he joins us now
was there a lag do you think in in
reporting these the seriousness of this
virus outbreak when it originated in
China dr. field I think there was a fog
of war situation it's hard to know who
is responsible when the first reports
were coming out there was misinformation
I don't know that it was willful I don't
know when we will know that I am kind of
focused on moving forward and not
looking back at that part of it so
that's why I would leave that right so
let's look forward or let's look at
where we are now I mean in the New York
City area the streets are empty Times
Square when I came across it today was
deserted people are taking seriously the
order to stay home and stay out of
crowds will that be enough to be
effective well it's it's very important
baseline I think that we have a whole
new set of behaviors that we really need
to adopt and as our society adapts to
the current situation we may be sending
some people out to work who work in
solitary professions like gardeners and
truck drivers and the rest of us will
have to remain in homes or more secluded
situations in order to keep the curve
flatter than it is right now do you see
any bright spots on the horizon is there
any good news coming out of this
pandemic in your view well I I do see
good news I think that Americans have
really risen to the challenge I haven't
heard a lot of grumbling I know that my
colleagues in their hospitals have kind
of taken a baton down
Hatch's let's clear the decks for action
attitude so here in the Sacramento area
there hasn't been there has been an
uptick in the number of cases but it
hasn't reached the level that we're
seeing in Los Angeles Louisiana New
Orleans of course New York and then my
company for instance is doing its best
to match doctors who have some excess
capacity with places hospitals and
clinics that need their help
the Chilean telemedicine we're getting
the flood of calls and we're working
24/7 to try to match those those doctors
with those necessary spots the doomsday
predictions that you know everybody was
hearing when when this crisis first
really started building in this country
do we know yet whether those are
accurate we don't know right now we're
still a week or two away from getting a
feel if you look at the curve of the
infection rate we're still on an
exponential rise and we're we're growing
faster than anywhere else in the world
unfortunately our daily caseload is
reaching up as high as listen just two
days ago it was less than half that at
8,000 so we're in a dangerous territory
but I do think there's reason to be
optimistic that many parts of our
country have heard the message and are
practicing social distancing we of
course in our business are sending
anybody who doesn't need to be in the
office home and we're spreading out the
workforce to minimize the risk of
infection everybody's being more careful
about sneezing coughing I think that we
could wear masks to prevent the
transmission remember here's here's the
truth that for every person who's tested
positive there are at least eight to ten
asymptomatic people people who don't
even know they have it walking around
with the infection so maybe is more of
mask wearing when we have the masks
available will be helpful but there is
reason to be optimistic that we're not
we're not going to see our country
crushed by this but it's also true that
that you don't want you know people who
happen to have access to n95 masks you
don't want them walking to the grocery
store using that mask those should be
reserved for medical personnel in
hospitals right absolutely right now
they do need to be reserved there but
when we move from a position of scarcity
to one of surplus which we probably will
in the next several days or weeks then
we might see everybody spreading the
masks around to further reduce
transmission and since you you mentioned
kind of hit upon hoarding I really want
to speak out against hydroxychloroquine
hoarding that that I don't know that
that's an issue elsewhere I know that
none of my colleagues are hoarding this
medicine I personally am NOT and I think
it would be terrible I also don't think
there's any strong evidence that it is
is doing the job that we're hoping in
eliminating this virus dr. Dan field
from m.d. staffers we appreciate your
expertise thank you